pas
[Musique]
le mercredi c'est unss et ce jour de
championnat académique de danse
des dizaines d'élèves passionnés de
toute l'île se prépare dans le théâtre
départemental le champ fleuri on se
confie au fond de la classe
le professeur de ps prend ce jour-là sa
casquette de chorégraphes le prennent
beaucoup de plaisir
six ont bossé qui méritent de passer un
bon moment sur scène entre eux son
mérite
une fois un pilote comme ça quand on est
au fond c'est justement jared j'ai pas
été de leur dire que c'était vraiment
une très grande chance qu'il avait de se
retrouver ici aujourd'hui c'est un grand
plaisir c'est une belle scène c'est un
beau théâtre il ya une âme une vraie âme
j'espère que ça va aller
des transcender
[Musique]
et
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on gagne et on perd en france et six
écrans on a peur on avait l'habitude
aidant ces deux grands et aussi beaucoup
de gens qui nous regardent au
département aussi le croyons en la
réunion des talents en la réunion de
l'excellence et on la réunion qui gagne
le département bien évidemment oeuvre en
tous les cas beaucoup pour la jeunesse
réunionnaise et par ce biais du nss
jeudi montre que les jeunes envie de
s'épanouir ont envie d'aller beaucoup
plus loin et loin ça nous permet permet
en tous les cas la jeunesse réunionnaise
de les faire connaître d'une part et de
pouvoir aller au plus haut niveau
nous les bonnes après midi mon premier
loge un groupe prend des notes et parmi
les membres du jury des élèves motivés
on a déjà 16 2 mois 16 en eps dans le
brevet ça ouvre plein porte d'être juge
et on adore la danse et c'est pour ça ça
ne tient à coeur de faire ça et de
pouvoir juger ça nous apprend aussi à
pouvoir critiquer notre propre
chorégraphie pour le futur pas un simple
spectacle nous formons des futurs
citoyens en réussite pour certains qui
vont aller en championnat de france mais
pas que concourir il y en a qui vont
juger qu'ils vont devenir jeune juge
national et bien entendu ça n'est pas
qu'un spectacle puisque
f chaque chorégraphie il ya un argument
une idée directrice
une émotion
[Musique]
pendant près de deux heures les
collégiens puis les lycéens donnent le
meilleur d'eux mêmes jusqu'au bout des
doigts ces jeunes expriment leur
ressenti et partagent leurs émotions
cela donne du sens à l'accompagnement
financier des associations sportives des
collèges par le département
[Musique]
satané la chorégraphie ce qui me met
dans les moments les plus durs où on est
fatigué ou aux limites on en épuiser bas
on continue à y croire parce que on vide
la danse tous les jours et pas pour nous
une grande opportunité ben je sais pas
parce que le coup d'oeil sur la bande
qui me donnent beaucoup d'amour beaucoup
de passion famille windows est toujours
uni malgré tout
[Applaudissements]
et on remercie notre preuve les
merveilleuses et quatre ans nous aussi
du début jusqu'à la fin
elle s'appelle brial martin des jeunes
bien dans leur peau
reconnaissant dans des projets
collectifs une fois de plus la pratique
sportive montre sa pertinence sociale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]